The 12,024 Calendar is here!
Get itnow before it sells out.
And staytuned until the end of this video for
a sneak peek that’s out of this world.
Life has existed on one planet for about 4
billion years, as far as we know. But it might
have started right after the Big Bang, when
the universe was much stranger and more fantastic
than today. A universe that might have allowed
life to develop absolutely anywhere. The cosmos
might be full of the seeds of life, sleeping
in a dead desert, waiting for a few drops
of rain to explosively bloom and grow. Tiny
and not so tiny aliens might be everywhere.
In this video we are going to put together
two highly speculative yet scientifically
grounded possibilities – check out the scientific
papers in our sources. To properly explain it
let's first look at the paradox of life
on Earth.
The Life Paradox
For its first few hundred million years,
Earthwas a magma hell constantly
bombarded by asteroids.
But basically the second things calmed down
and the first oceans formed, life just appeared
and zillions of microbes settled every
nook and cranny they found.
This is kind of strange – life on Earth
seems to be almost as old as the planet itself.
As if it was waiting around for an opportunity.
But life didn’t only appear extremely quickly:
in that tiny time window,
it also crossed a huge gap.
To qualify as living things, even microbes
need to eat, poop, grow and multiply.
To do that, they need a genome,
the biological instructionmanual
that sets the inner workings of an organism.
How dead things with no genome became living
things with genomes is one of the biggest
riddles of science. Simplifying a lot, the
problem is that to have a functioning genome
you need proteins, and to make those proteins
you need a functioning genome. Both proteins
and genomes are super long molecules
made of pretty complex blocks
that are extremely difficult
to assemble bychance.
It is a chicken-eggparadox
with several chickens and eggs.
Once you have a finished cell, the whole system
works efficiently. But starting from simple
dead stuff and reaching
that level of sophistication
by pure chance should require an amazing amount
of time for trial and error. So how did the
first living things manage to cross that gap
in just a few hundred million years?
Most theories about the origin of life try
to explain that gap by theorizing how some
primitive soup of prebiotic molecules
couldhave efficiently produced
the first self replicating entities.
But we still don’t know how exactly
this would have worked.
Maybe we need to think backwards.
The Clock of Evolution
Think of genomes as a book telling the history
of life. As time passed and life evolved,
more characters were introduced: Amoebae,
fish, amphibians, dinosaurs and mammals.
Over billions of years, the story
of lifegot more and more complex.
A genome can be viewed as a long string
of letters with biological instructions.
And from microbes to us today, functional
genomes seem to have been increasing in size
at a fairly constant rate.
The functional genome of fish is more than twice
that of worms; our functional genome is about
twice bigger than that of fish and so on.
It is a bit more complicated, but for now
let’s run with this.
When we put all these clues together,
it seems that genomes have been doubling in
size on average every 350 million years or
so. As if evolution had been following an
exponential inner clock.
But it gets even stranger.
The very first microbes that emerged on Earth,
even if they look simple, already seem to
have had pretty long and complex genomes.
But how could life have achieved that level
of complexity in such a short time?
There may be an interesting way to solve this
riddle: We just take our exponential clock
and extrapolate it back in time, to the simplest
conceivable life form – something equivalent
to a being with a genome containing just a
few letters. But if we do that we end up
10 billion years in the past. More than twice
the age of Earth, which means: If life actually
evolved like this, it did not start here,
but somewhere out there, in space.
This would explain why life started to thrive
so quickly on our young planet. If it was
already present in space like a seed, it just
needed water and warm temperatures to wake
up and go on evolving. And it would also explain
the high degree of sophistication of the first
life forms on Earth. They could have been
complex already because they might have been
evolving for billions of years
somewhere else in the universe.
But could life really be that old? Maybe yes.
Actually, life could have started shortly
after the universe itself was born.
A Goldilocks Baby Universe
At its most basic level life needs two things:
the right chemical elements to form complex
molecules and a liquid medium like water,
in which those molecules can move and interact.
The liquid medium needs to stay warm enough
to remain, well, liquid.
So when we search for life in space, we focus
on Earth-like planets at just the right distance
from their star – warm enough to sustain
liquid water.
But there was actually a time when almost
all of the universe might have been habitable.
Right after the Big Bang the universe was
extremely hot. But as the cosmos expanded,
it cooled. And between about 10 and 17 million
years after the Big Bang, when the universe
was a thousand times younger than today, it
was between 100 ºC and 0 ºC – the temperature
at which water is liquid. So for this window
of time, more than 13.7 billion years ago,
the whole universe, absolutely every
inch of it, had the right temperature
to support life.
Of course, the right temperature
alone is not enough for life. We also need
chemical elements like carbon and oxygen,
which are forged in the cores of stars.
But were there stars in super early cosmic times?
Maybe yes – in regions of the universe where
matter was especially dense. Such stars
would have been very massive and gone supernova
in just 3 million years – seeding the baby
universe with the chemical elements needed
to form dust, asteroids,planets
and the ingredientsof life.
Maybe the first ancestors of life were more
exotic and didn’t even need water, but thrived
in substances like ammonia or ethane that
can stay liquid at temperatures far below
0 °C. They could have been sustained by the
lingering warmth of the Big Bang for tens
of millions of years longer, well into a time
when we know for sure there were stars and
all the chemical elements.
The real magic of this idea is that while
the universe today is extremely deadly and
hostile, back then the conditions for life
might have been basically everywhere.
For a period that may have lasted several dozen
million years, primordial life might have been
able to emergeon any rock,
even between the stars
- sowing the universe with the
seeds of what, billions of years later,
would become bacteria,
trilobites, dinosaurs, and finally us.
At some point the universe cooled below the
right temperature for life to thrive, but
some of those ancestral life forms may have
continued to exist in the internal warmth
of the first planets, frozen in asteroids
or hibernating in cosmic dust – tiny seeds
roaming the cosmos waiting for new hospitable
places to continue evolving. If they did,
life now might be everywhere in the universe.
Will We Ever Know?
All this makes for a nice story. And while
both the habitability of the baby universe
and our exponential clock of life
are reasonable ideas
– they are still speculative.
One more possibility among many others, trying
to explain our existence today.
But if life came to Earth from outer space,
then it should have seeded other places in
the solar system too. Maybe there are fossils
in dry riverbeds on Mars. Maybe we’ll soon
find life in the warm underground oceans of
Enceladus or Europa. Titan has seas, rivers
and lakes of ethane and methane as warm as
the universe when it was 90 million years
old. So finding exotic life on Titan would
support the idea that life could have originated
in the weird baby universe.
So far, when we look out into the cosmos we
don’t see anyone like us. But maybe that's
because life needed ten billion years or
more to reach the level of complexity that
allows for a technological species. Maybe
there are millions of worlds filled with microbes,
oceans full of exotic fish, and continents
of bizarre animals. And maybe even others
like us, that just recently gained consciousness
and are beginning to look at the sky,
wondering if they are alone.
Life could be flourishing right now in uncountable
forms and in all kinds of cosmic environments.
And if many of us share a common cosmic origin,
we would all be part of a great cosmic family.
The answer may lie in our cosmic backyard.
Let’s go and find out!
It’s time. Let’s reveal the 12,024
HumanEra Calendar with a Big Bang!
The kurzgesagtcalendar is special because we are adding
10,000 years, to include all of humanity
no matter their culture or origin.
12,000 years ago humans first started
working together on a larger scale, laying the
foundation for civilization and the future of
us all. A much better representation
of how far our species has come!
This year we’re looking at the
cosmos and all the possible life that
could be thriving on myriads of worlds –
hosting radically different animals and
beings from the ones on earth.
Where in the universe might life exist?
And how would different cosmic
environments affect the basic rules of life?
Join us in 12,024 and find out!
Explore strange cosmic habitats and
extraterrestrial life forms on 12 awe-inspiring
pages. There is also lots of room for you to
keep track of your life here on Earth.
Add some serious space magnificence
to your home but be careful – the
extremely radiant cover may blind you.
Get the calendar now before it
sells out. We also have bundles
and special calendar deals with
some of your favorite products.
Thank you so much to all of the thousands
of birbs who get the calendar every year.
With every purchase you support
the kurzgesagt vision of sparking
curiosity and inspiring people all around
the world. We wish you an epic year 12,024!